you mentioned earlier about a writer
finding their own true voice within
their work how did you find yours well I
came out of theatre and when I was first
in theater I presumed everyone in
theater would become an actor but I
wasn't a very good actor and I even took
private lessons and my acting teacher
said this is not natural to you she says
now if you want to work through whatever
block you have you know you can't we can
work on that but she said you know other
people as this flow is out of them much
more and I began to recognize that it
was in the field of first directing and
then literature and then I developed
this method in graduate school that
became the method that I use for my
consulting and when I started consulting
I realized it brought together all these
different parts of me I had a good
psychology background so I understood
the writer I had studied creativity
several years I knew about my own
creativity and it helped me understand
their creativity and I realized I was a
nurturer I was very good at nurturing
that creativity out of other people and
then when I started my business I sort
of just went for it
and I went to a very good career
consultant who helped me affirm that
voice and a long the way I had a mentor
a excellent teacher in graduate school
that kind of rather than saying you go
down this path he would watch the path I
was going down and he would encourage me
and he would he taught me how to be bold
don't be afraid to go out on a limb
don't be afraid her had something you
check it you know a certain extent but
says don't be afraid and so I began to
be much better about stepping out and
finding my own way
and the more I could get out of that
coat competition and just say look I'm
only called to be me I'm not asked to be
anything else and and I would go astray
and thankfully I had some good friends
that would say do you really want the
porsche above anything else and the war
holders there's something stronger and i
I think sometimes you keep saying what
is exactly my goal and you work at
defining that I mean if somebody said
what is my life about I would say my
life is about nurturing creativity and
spirituality and I see that these things
come together and so I mean I have this
odd degree a doctorate in drama and
theology which is the least marketable
degree you could get in the world but in
terms of the integration I think so many
writers want to do something important I
say why do we write we write because we
want to change the world we want to
inspire we want to examine and explore
and express the human condition and you
know so we we let that kind of flow out
of us so you keep your mind on the
bigger goal and you think what am I
about and I just have to stay true to
that and you know and sometimes just to
learn to phrase what it is that I am
about what's my what's my mission or
what's important here and that helps
competition with an article sometimes
even is competition it could be solely
within us what could be solely when
someone else but it sounds like once you
define that you just live by that kind
of code yes and we help each other a lot
my colleagues and I especially several
of them we call and sometimes when we
feel that sense whether it's competition
or anger or repute about something we
call the other person say okay I gotta
work through this and so I have several
colleagues and sometimes I call you know
like Pamela J Smith and I said I have to
be caddy for about 30 seconds and Pamela
says oh yeah
go ahead my dear and so there are times
that you do I mean you do have those
feelings and I never want to negate that
one has those feelings but what I do is
I have several colleagues that are on
call and
when I call them and say I just have to
be kind of my ugly self for a moment
here is that okay like oh yes honey go
right ahead okay
got it out of my system okay because I
will have those feelings at times and
whatever those feelings are uncertainty
and security you know anger we can go on
and on about what those are and say so
yes having somebody to talk to having
good colleagues really valuing those
relationships and being there to be
generous to each other and to help each
other to recommend jobs for each other
to see what we can do for each other
knowing we all have our part to play in
this whole industry
you